i was prime minister um
at the time of september the 11th
i took the decision that we should
support america and
the nations
from all around the world
in removing the taliban from government
there because they were sheltering al
qaeda who were responsible for the 9 11
attack and we're and we're not prepared
to yield them up
we've had 20 years of yeah immense
difficulty but also
real progress
and
i think the problem was that
in the end with these situations you've
got to be prepared to commit
for the long term and i know how
difficult it is to do that but the truth
is when we came to the end of 2019
we were in a situation where troop
levels were significantly down america
had a few thousand troops nato had
something like 8 000 troops
the country could have been held through
the next phase of its progress
but then we decided for political
reasons that we had to withdraw under
the previous american administration and
then under this one and even though i
understand how difficult these things
are
if it matters and i think afghanistan
did matter and does matter to us you've
got to be prepared to to hold to your
course over the long term
and and to see it through
even though it's difficult and even
though it's painful because it matters
to our security as well as of course to
the people of afghanistan
20 years on do you were looking at the
situation in afghanistan now and it's
going backwards do you regret going in
at that time if you think now it looks
like not much has really changed for the
people of afghanistan i think it's
important to realize when you talk to
afghans and i've talked to some in the
last few days i mean they're actually in
this last 20 years has been a lot of
progress
i mean when you think of the
the economy is about three times the
size it was 20 years ago
um
this year there would have been roughly
200 000 afghans going to university of
which 50 000 were women
you know if you look at the education
system and how it's changed
and remember the majority of afghans
have grown up not under the taliban it's
a young population
now i i think this story is not over for
afghanistan and it's very clear to me
speaking to people
that that there will be
a real desire on the part of the people
in afghanistan many of them if they can
to to
to change what has happened
but
this was not a situation we needed to be
in the truth is we were making progress
and
the the decision to withdraw which
really began with the agreement of
february 2020 under the previous
american administration that decision
was taken essentially for internal
american reasons which i understand i
mean i completely get it
but
we didn't need to do it for the success
of the mission in afghanistan we could
have held firm and we could have
succeeded
imbecilic is the word that you've used
to describe it
but there is obviously a feeling from a
lot of world leaders that they just
wanted out of it after 20 years the
money and the lives that were lost
yeah look i i i
i support a lot of what president biden
has done since becoming president i mean
i have a great respect and admiration
for him as a person and i understand he
inherited this agreement of february
2020 which which was very difficult and
i also understand if you're a political
leader you're under political pressure
people people want the engagement to end
but we've got to realize we were in a
situation where our engagement was
dramatically different from where it was
10 years ago never mind 20 years ago
and where we could have managed the
situation and the problem with what
what's happened now this is this is my
worry is it's not just about the afghan
people and our obligation to them and
and obviously you know you feel i mean
distressed when you see
when you see people realizing what
they're going to lose as a result of the
taliban coming back into power but it's
not just about the afghan people it's
about us and our security because you've
now got this group back in charge of
afghanistan
they will give
protection and sucker to al-qaeda
you've got isis already
in the country trying to operate at the
same time
you know
you look around the world
and the only people really cheering this
decision are the people hostile to
western interests
do you think inevitably that britain and
its allies will end up back in
afghanistan because of what you've just
said
i i can't tell the one the one thing i
know is right now the most immediate
thing
is that and britain can do this as the
head of the g7 at the moment we should
be putting together the leading
countries who are part of this coalition
in the first place and who supported
afghanistan the last 20 years
and we need to work out what our
strategy and tactics are going to be in
respect to the taliban government and we
need to be drawing up a list of
incentives
and
um
sanctions and other things that we can
do in order to use the leverage we have
which is not
which is not insignificant i mean
remember this this is a an afghan
government that's been receiving large
amounts of aid from the us from japan
from the uk from other countries
um
it's you know the taliban will find
that governing is a lot harder than they
thought the population of afghanistan is
different
it's not going to just be prepared to to
to go under
some form of of
um horrific you know seventh century
laws and practices so there's going to
be a lot that we can still do but it's
important that we mobilize now after the
disarray frankly of the last few weeks
that we mobilize as the leading
countries and make it clear
that we still understand we have an
obligation in our own interests to try
and resolve this situation and to put as
much pressure on the the government in
afghanistan as possible to make sure
that we don't end up either with a
security threat back in play for us
or with
the afghan people losing the gains
they've made over the last 20 years
have you spoken to joe biden recently
no i haven't but you know i as i say
i've have an enormous respect for joe
biden i've known him for many many years
and he's he's a good man he's a decent
man and i understand that once this
agreement of february 2020 was entered
into it became you know difficult but on
the other hand
by the way the agreement of february
2020 made by the previous american
administration with the taliban
it was conditional
on changes of behavior by the taliban
and they broke the terms of that
agreement i mean
literally without any compunction
whatever so
i think it's important to realize this
is not something we needed to do
um and
you know again i understand the
political pressure but
our footprint in afghanistan had really
been
reduced to to to a much much smaller
level and as i say by the end of 2019 we
were in a situation where we could have
held firm
for some considerable time and helped
the afghan people through the next
stages of their progress
i saw it described as a stain on the
west this morning i mean we really can't
take a moral high ground about global
issues like yemen for example hong kong
if
what's going on in afghanistan people
falling from planes babies being passed
by desperate parents to soldiers who may
never see their children again
i think part of the problem is that
over the last 20 years we've heard all
the bad news out of afghanistan and i
don't think there was a lot of knowledge
until literally these last few weeks
amongst our own public opinion
that yes there had been real
difficulties and all the time it's tough
because you've got the taliban with
external support always trying to
sabotage progress blow up roads and
bridges
assassinate people who are trying to do
good things in afghanistan so it was a
very tough time over this 20 years but i
think it's only in the last few weeks
when you read the the really
heart-rending accounts
by people of what they fear under the
taliban that you realize that there were
a lot of gains in this last 20 years
and so i think
the problem is that
that the west has to understand that
when we do something like this the
signal it sends out
is one of in constancy
it's it's it's it's one that says look
if the going gets tough
we're out but you you can't
in the world that we have today
you've got sometimes to commit for the
long term and you've got to commit for
the long term
because you made a strategic assessment
of your interests and because yes even
if it becomes unpopular from time to
time and public opinion
your job then as a leader is to go out
and explain why it's necessary despite
that
to hold firm because when you don't hold
firm
then
those people who are opposed to you
whether these islamist groups or um
russia china iran all of whom will move
into the vacuum we've created you know
those people who are not on our side and
who don't wish us well are going to gain
by it
realistically could britain have done
anything else given that the u.s said
look we are going we are not going to
support you
britain didn't really have any other
choice did it
well we couldn't we couldn't stay there
without the american support
and and i don't know enough about what
internal conversations there been but
but certainly my view is we we should
have been maybe we were so i'm not
criticizing anyone but
we should have been arguing very
strongly as to why this was the wrong
thing to do
whether you like it or not it is part of
your legacy what would you say to the
soldiers who we've heard from this week
that have been
horrifically injured in afghanistan and
the widows of soldiers who have died and
they're saying well there was no point
to this was there they went to fight a
war that was completely pointless and
it's going back to how it was
legal troops were fantastic in
afghanistan and a lot of them made the
ultimate sacrifice a lot of them were
injured
and it's really important that they know
that this wasn't a hopeless endeavor and
it wasn't a bad cause it was a good
cause you know we went there because we
had a
state of afghanistan turned in
to a state that was run by a an
extremist islamist group that were
harboring people who were carrying out
attacks
you know like the 9 11 attack and who
were providing support for terrorist
groups around the world we went in there
for very good reasons and we achieved a
lot thanks to those british and american
and other armed forces over the last 20
years and what i'd say to them is
the sacrifice was not in vain that those
20 years by the way matter
you know what we achieve in afghanistan
it matters today i actually spoke
yesterday to a
uh an afghan
general who himself was fighting the
taliban just literally days ago
and he said
you know do not forget we made huge
progress during those 20 years we we my
generation has grown up knowing
something different from the taliban and
we're determined at some stage and in
some way to get our country back so i
think it's really important that people
realize now this the story of
afghanistan and the story of the taliban
takeover it's not over
it's it's tragic what's happened i think
it's unnecessary i think we've made a
serious mistake in doing this in this
way
but it isn't over yet
given what we found out about dominic
ralph's actions or inaction over the
last week should he still have a job
should he still be foreign secretary
you know i'm just concentrating on what
i think we should do now as a country i
don't really want to get into
individual actions of government
ministers and frankly it's it's really
not a question of where anyone was at
any particular time it's it's a question
of what we do now but it's about taking
responsibility isn't it and you know we
found out that the the minister for
afghanistan he was on his holidays
dominic robb was on his holidays and you
need people to be present in a crisis
well you need people to be contactable
certainly um
and and active during a crisis but i
don't i don't want to you know there's
plenty of people commenting on that
that's not my my the purpose of writing
what i did but what i wanted to do was
to say
two things first in the immediate term
this is what we need to do and i've
suggested that the britain convene this
contact group and you've got to get the
allies operating with a sense of
coherence and purpose and direction and
that is very very urgent to do
and the second thing is just to to to
say in a more reflective way
we in the west have got to decide is
this radical islamist threat a threat
that we think
warrants
a strategic long-term commitment by us
to defeat it now i happen to think that
it is if we don't think that that's fine
but i'm looking around the world today
and
you know i'm just seeing that this
this islamist threat is still there
these groups are still proliferating
there are many different parts of the
world getting destabilized by them and i
personally think we have an interest
britain the united states our allies
in pushing back hard against this threat
now that doesn't mean to say you're
always going to be doing you know
full-scale conflict and so on but it
does mean to say that you take a
long-term strategic view of your
interests and how to to satisfy them and
that really was the purpose of what i'm
writing because many people as a result
of what's happened in afghanistan
are going to have a
deep doubt as to whether we can be
relied upon
and that is not a good thing
your
your friends should have confidence
and your foes should always be worried
and the trouble with this decision is
that our friends are now
anxious
and those people opposed to us
feel heartened by it and that is not a
good place to be
we can recover it but it's going to
require us actively to do it are you
hoping by using words like in basilic
very strong language that people will
listen that it won't just get lost in
the commentary of what's going on that
word was attached to the slogan and it's
a slogan's been used by people of all
um
political stripes in the u.s you know
forever wars and the reason i i don't
agree with the slogan is that it first
of all it's not that you've got a you're
not in afghanistan in the same way that
you were 10 or 20 years ago you know we
had a manageable situation we could have
carried on managing it and helping the
country but it's also because
in the end and as i say i say this
despite i've got a huge respect for joe
biden as a as a president and as a
person
a policy
can't be decided by slogan it's got to
be decided on the basis of a strategy
and that's a different thing
and that's really the purpose of what i
was saying you've got to
you know your political slogans are one
thing for campaigns but when you're
looking
at the long-term interests of your
country when you've got a position of
leadership in the world it's important
that you you
you take a step back and you really
you really analyze deeply
what a what is in the interest not just
of your
country and its allies but in the
interest of your own values i just want
to express finally you're obviously in
touch with people in afghanistan do they
do they get a sense that people actually
care or do they think they like you said
they can't rely on people anymore and
they're they're going to be forgotten
and left to it with the taliban
suppressing women's rights i mean that's
a kind way of putting it children being
denied education and anyone who goes
against them is is murdered
i think people in afghanistan
you know they've been through so much in
the last decades
you remember we had the i mean one of
the really sad things about afghanistan
is if you get
some old pictures out from the 1960s
of afghanistan
you'll see it was a country that
had a real future
a moderate country
and
unfortunately they've had literally
almost
half a century
of of of difficulty and and
you know hardship but there is a
there is a group of young people today
who've tasted some of the freedom in the
last 20 years
and i think they will
they will they will find a way
to to reassert themselves and i think
what we've got to
to decide now is
and we should do this on a coordinated
basis with the key countries coming
together is what can we do to help and
support them
and yes of course a lot of afghans at
the moment will feel that they've been
betrayed but i think
it's possible for us to show in time
because we do have some leverage in this
situation
that we still
have a sense of obligation to them and
to our own strategic security interests
and can help and we should
go back 20 years would you do it again
well i've no doubt at the time it was
the right thing
to do because if if you have a
a terrorist attack killing three and a
half thousand innocent people
in in the united states of america and
it comes out of a country run by an
extremist government harboring the
people who
carried out that terrorist attack and
would carry out then more terrorist
attacks if you allow them to carry on
doing so
look we we felt at the time and i
believe rightly that there was no
alternative but to say to the taliban
government at the time you either give
up the al-qaeda leadership or we're
going to remove you from government
so
the point is
this could have turned out differently
and it should have um and i'm you know i
don't
as i'm not
criticizing
people in a in a foolish way i know how
difficult it is to take these decisions
we made mistakes
um you know a lot of mistakes have been
made but the fact is the country did
have a chance
and it was really our own internal
short-term politics
um in the west that has driven in the
last couple of years us to to put at
risk what we gained and i think it's
only now that we're realizing in in this
moment of crisis exactly how much we
gained and how foolish it is to lose it